[Music]
hi my name is Kalin Ashley I'm here
today with Matthew and we're gonna turn
him into the night king from Game of
Thrones so the night king is obviously a
very elaborate prosthetic makeup it's
definitely a pretty like big undertaking
for a Halloween costume but if you're
also but if you're interested in doing
something like this these are all
prosthetics that are available on the
market and you could purchase to do
yourself we're gonna start out with a
bald cap we're also gonna get him into
some contact lenses we're just gonna be
our first step we want to make sure that
the lenses are in so he can get adjusted
to them as well as you know we don't to
put them in one of the makers already
done so Matthew I'm gonna go ahead and
have you done all right let's go
[Music]
awesome Matthew those look great
so now we're gonna go ahead and getting
started the first thing you want to do
is prep your skin you want to make sure
that there aren't any oils on the skin
the first thing that we do is we take a
stringent or a toner and just kind of
knock back any oils on the face now I'm
going in with a skin protectant called
derma shield this is just gonna create a
nice little barrier between the
prosthetic and the adhesive and his face
so the next thing up in our process is
we're gonna do a bald cap on you when
you do a bald cap you want to make sure
that you bring the hair down as tight as
possible I like to use a product called
gafquat but gel or any other type of
kind of hair product will do
so now I'm gonna go ahead and put a bald
cap on you but before we get too ahead
of ourselves why don't you go ahead and
take your shirt off we're gonna do a
prosthetic that'll probably stop here
and so it'll be easier to do that now
that I'm sure I'm gonna be using a
medical grade adhesive called Fras a
this is an acrylic based adhesive it's a
lot better than something like spirit
gum it'll last a lot longer so to make
this process go a little faster I'm
going to bring in my assistant Callie
come on in
so to really take this looks to the next
level we're gonna go ahead and use some
full face prosthetics
these are prosthetics by Worf store
they're a company based in Florida but
you can get them online and you can
order them and have them shipped to you
these are awesome way of making your
Halloween costume take it to the next
level if you don't have these are a
little intimidated by these you can also
do this look with a face paint it's
totally fine now that we've got the face
piece lightened up I have these horns
that I picked up it's gonna be a little
bit more inspired night king but these
are just generic little devil horns you
can pick up online there by a rubber
wear at the same company that makes
these ear tips and these are a great way
to add just some quick little horn
action like the night king has well
Kelly's blending I'm gonna go ahead and
apply his neck that way it'll line up
right underneath his chin and you're
working with PRIZE a the thing you want
to remember is as long as this adhesive
is a bit shiny you want to make sure
like you want to powder it to lose that
shine it's always gonna be tacky until
you powder it and so I just take a
little bit of a translucent powder you
can use baby powder and a pinch and you
just want a powder those shiny spots
this piece is gonna absorb any product
unless you seal it so what I typically
like to do is take a product called pax
paint pax paint is the same project
adhesive mixed with a little bit of
acrylic to tint it if you don't have
that you can just use straight up
prostate and coat the prosthetic with
just solid prosody and then move on to
your paint I'm gonna go ahead and take a
water activated paint this is a Kryolan
aqua color you can buy this at any kind
of makeup supply store these are awesome
especially if you don't want to do any
kind of heavy duty paint work these you
can do straight to skin there like I
said water activated my personal
preference is to paint using a sea
sponge you can buy these at any Target
Walmart if they've got an art supply
section
so now that we've sealed this prosthetic
in we're just gonna go in and sponge
this aqua color all over the face so now
that we've got this nice like kind of
off-white base tone I'm gonna go ahead
and set the Aqua colors with this
awesome
pro seal by European body art it's just
going to help seal all that paint in so
that when I lay other colors down it
doesn't get lifted up now that I've got
the base down down and sealed I'm gonna
go in with some darker blues and grays
and blacks into some of these crevices
and just bring it more to that night
King aesthetic that we can recognize I'm
using an alcohol activated paint by
European body art and I'm just gonna go
ahead and run it through my airbrush and
start bringing this together and I'm
just gonna with my airbrush follow along
the prosthetic and kind of bring this
texture up into the bald cap he's got a
lot of really fun kind of texture and
Anatomy in the head as well so I'm
trying to replicate that using the
airbrush and some paint all of these
techniques you could do with a hand
painted and body paint as well gonna
switch back to the alcohol thing just to
kind of reinforce some of the colors
I like to layer both hand painting and
airbrush techniques gives it a little
bit more of a realistic feel to it it
doesn't feel so for lack of a better
word airbrush II I'm using an alcohol
activated palette I'm gonna go in just
kind of detail get into the crevices
that I can't get in with my airbrush
just using kind of a navy blue there's
not actually a ton of blue in the night
king makeup but you want to give it a
little hints of that snow a lot of the
blue that you see in any other shots are
more camera or surrounding based using
more of a off-white tone and just kind
of going in and hitting some highlight
points now I'm taking just the two
liquid alcohol paints and adding a
little bit of alcohol to that making it
a little bit of a thinner mixture that
way I can fill it into some of these
gaps
it'll fall into the cracks and then I
can just wipe away the excess I'm gonna
get a darker blue cream out so I can get
right up to his waterline I always want
to use a cream around the eye area it's
just safer and more comfortable than
using an alcohol paint and you don't
want to use a water-based paint around
the eyes because if they tear up it'll
just kind of wash away just hitting it
with a little bit more sealer just to
kind of melt the paint's in together
okay Matthew are you ready to get into
your white Walker wardrobe yes I'm
excited all right awesome let's get you
fitted for it
[Music]
hi my name is Kalin Ashley and thank you
so much for watching my transformation
of Matthew here into the night kick yeah
thanks so much this looks incredible and
thanks for watching me become the night
king from HBO's Game of Thrones
you
you